this video is part of a series that
expands on the basics of historical
linguistics by exploring various types
of regular sound changes
today's sound changes assimilation two
sounds are involved here and one of them
becomes more like the other the
assimilating phoneme picks up one or
more of the features of another nearby
phoning the Latin root sim is the key
here the two sounds become more similar
you've learned about phonemes and their
features in my series the IPA for
language learning the place of
articulation and manner of articulation
of consonants will come in especially
handy for the basics of assimilation
let's take an example the Latin phoneme
done has the features dental glow Civ
and voiced the phoneme s has the
features alveolar fricative the Latin
word add prefixed to the word C Malatya
results in the pronunciation as simila
tio in other words D comes to share all
the features of the nearby s and is
completely assimilated to s
speakers of languages the world over use
assimilation to make words easier to
pronounce
for ease of articulation there are
different types of assimilation does the
assimilating sound take on every feature
of the phoneme that triggered
assimilation if so the assimilation is
complete if it only takes on some of or
even just one of the features that's
only a partial assimilation the
assimilation in the Latin assimilate
tool above is complete but when I
pronounce n as M before P in input
that's a partial assimilation the two
sounds are both by labial but one's a
nasal and the others are closed it are
the two sounds side by side we'll call
that contiguous assimilation are they
more distant from each other not
adjacent that's non contiguous the two
examples of assimilation I have given
you both involved contiguous phonemes if
my tongue gets twisted and I
accidentally say Russian submarine for
Russian submarine the assimilation is
non-contiguous
does the change sound come after the
sound it's assimilating to that's a
regressive assimilation or is it heard
before the sound it's assimilating too
that would be a progressive assimilation
my embarrassing mispronunciation Russian
submarine is an instance of a regressive
assimilation but the assimilation of n2p
and input is a fine example of a
progressive assimilation we can also
label assimilations by the features that
are changed in the process if the
assimilating phoneme is originally
voiceless does it pick up the feature
voice from the other sound this sound
change is called voicing
nearly all vowels in human language are
voiced consonants often become voiced
between vowels some Italian speakers
pronounce the phoneme su or s between
two vowels as Z like in la mia casa my
house the change from s to Z is an
instance of intervocalic voicing if the
assimilated phoneme is voiced does it
pick up the feature voiceless from the
other sound or from being at the end of
a word that's the opposite phenomenon
called devoicing so the word have ends
in the voiced phoneme foot the word 2
begins with the voiceless T some
speakers D voice the 2 foot when they
pronounce the expression have two as
hafta does the assimilating sound move
its place of articulation closer to the
palate this happens when the sound its
assimilating to already has a palatal or
near palatal place of articulation this
is called palatalization and it's
significant triggers include the
consonant young and the vowel e for
instance some English speakers pronounce
the word student as student in rapid
speech the alveolar to assimilates to
the palatal yeah and becomes palatal
alveolar chuck student does the
assimilating sound change its manner of
articulation so that the airflow is
closer to a fricative
this is fricative ization and less
restricted sounds trigger this kind of
change including fricatives and vowels
stops often undergo this assimilation
I've both heard and said the
mispronunciation up through for up
through that pronunciation freak advises
the plosive puck as it assimilates to
the fricative of course the phoneme can
assimilate to any place or manner of
articulation I won't list all of them
here further examples of assimilation to
specific places of articulation include
labial ization when the assimilating
sound becomes more labial and
valorisation when the
sound becomes more velar when it comes
to matters of articulation the
assimilating sound can become a flow Civ
and affricate and so on there's an
opposing change known as dissimilation
two sounds are involved here two but one
becomes less like the other the
disseminating phoneme loses one or more
of the features it shares with another
nearby phony the two phonemes become
more dissimilar as a result the English
phoneme huh is a voiceless bilabial stop
if you say Peter Piper picked a peck of
pickled peppers as fast as you can
chances are you'd assimilate one or more
peas by pronouncing them as an F here
becomes less like the surrounding peas
by turning from a stop into a fricative
but there are more serious examples in
language history the Latin root pedigree
comes into English as pilgrim rather
than peregrym the first are de simulator
to an L the simulation has the same
characteristics found in assimilation
they can be progressive or regressive
contiguous or non contiguous involve
voicing or D voicing and etc the one
consistent difference is that this
process involves two sounds becoming
less alike that's all for assimilation
and assimilation watch again next time
when I'll go over the kinds of sound
changes that involve adding and getting
rid of stuff
you